ضربات جويه متتاليه باستخدام طيران مسير
على مواقع غرب ليبيا اعلنت حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه انتهاء مرحلتها الاولى والبدء في
المرحله الثانيه منها والتي تستهدف اوكار
الجريمه بحسب رئيس الحكومه
مواقع خطوط التهريب وخطوط التهريب البشره
وتهريب البنزينه او دخول
الكوكايين والهيروين والمخدرات بجميع
انواعها خصومه يتهمونه باستغلال المطالب
الشعبيه لتحقيق اهداف سياسيه في ظل
التقارب بين مجلسين النواب والدوله استغل
ت هذه الاغراض اللي هي
تكسب بها راي عام كالعاده يعني كل حدث حتى
الاحداث النبيله تحاول تحولها
[موسيقى]
استغلها بشكل يخدم مصالحها
واحد منهم بيت نائب بيت نائب في مجلس
النواب تصفيه حسابات سياسيه هذا هو مدخله
منطقه ابو صره في مدينه الزاويه والتي كان
لها نصيب الاسد من القصف الجوي بالطيران
المسير الذي تديره حكومه الوحده الوطنيه
بطرابلس والتي تقول انها قصفت مواقعا
لتهريب البشر والوقود فيما يقول معارضوها
ان المواقع التي استهدفت هي لمعارضين بيبه
فقط
تاتي وتقصف منطقه سكانها امنون
في على سبه انك تعرف الارهاب فهذا والله
الى الظلم في المنطقه اعربوا عن خشيتهم من
ارسال حكومه الوحده قوه بريه ما يعني وفق
قولهم عوده الاقتتال في المنطقه الغربيه
وسط تداخلات سياسيه وقبليه منير الاشهب
ليبيا العربيه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات